NATIONAL WEATHER SERVICES IT IS
THE STRONGEST TYPHOON THE
REGION HAS SEEN THIS YEAR.
HEATED PROTESTS HAVE ERUPTED IN
SOME OF RUSSIA'S ETHNIC
MINORITY REGIONS OVER THE
GOVERNMENT'S MARBLE IS A SHOE
ORDER OVER THE WAR IN UKRAINE.
THE VIDEO FROM THE CAPITOL,
PREDOMINANTLY MUSLIM REGION,
1000 MILES FROM MOSCOW ARGUING
WITH POLICE.
QUESTIONING WHY THEIR CHILDREN
ARE BEING DRAFTED.
AND OTHER CONFRONTATIONS,
POLICE RESPONDED BY FORCE.
REV ACID BEEN REPORTED.
THIS VIDEO THAT YOU SEE THERE
SHOWS OFFICERS AGGRESSIVELY
PUSHING BACK ANTI DRAFT
DEMONSTRATORS.
THIS IS A BIG DEMONSTRATIONS AT
THIS RALLY IN THE FAR EASTERN
REPUBLIC THAT IS MORE THAN 3000
MILES FROM MOSCOW.
AUTHORITIES THERE HAVE
ACKNOWLEDGED SOME RESIDENTS
WERE ENLISTED BY MISTAKE.
MANY RUSSIANS ARE TRYING TO
EVADE CONSCRIPTION BY FLEEING
THE COUNTRY.
AT THE BORDER WITH GEORGIA,
HUNDREDS OF CARS.
LOOK AT THAT.
LI WAITED IN LINE TO GET OUT OF
RUSSIA.
ONE MAN SPOKE ABOUT CHALLENGES
HE FACED AND GETTING THROUGH
THE LAST MAJOR RUSSIAN CITY
BEFORE HITTING THAT BORDER.
>> THERE'S WILD CORRUPTION.
IT'S INCREDIBLE.
YOU HAVE TO PAY POLICE TO
ENTER.
THIS HAPPENS TO FIXERS WHO
SOLVE THE ISSUE.
YOU PAY MONEY AND GET THROUGH
THROUGH A CHECKPOINTS SET UP TO
DEAL WITH JUST THE BORDER.
SO, PAID MONEY TO GET THERE AND
THEY NEED TO PAY MORE TO GET
OUT.
>> WE HAVE MORE NOW FROM CLOSE
SPECIALIST AND A BUY IN
ISTANBUL.
CLARE, THERE IS A CLEAR
STRATEGY FROM THE KREMLIN,
RIGHT?
RECORD FROM THE REGIONS.
MINORITY POPULATIONS.
YET, THIS IS ALSO PROVEN TO BE
A RISKY BET.
IT SEEMS TO BE BACKFIRING AT
THE MOMENT.
>> YEAH.
I THINK IT'S FAIR TO ASSUME
THAT THERE IS SOME STRATEGY.
PRESIDENT PUTIN RETURNS TO THE
PRESIDENCY AND 2012, HE WAS
ACCOMPANIED BY SOME OF THE
BIGGEST --
PIECES OF ALL THE SOVIET UNION.
CONCENTRATED IN THE BIG CITIES.
CLEARLY EVIDENCE BY THE WAY HE
GOVERNS.
SINCE THEN, HE WAS RATTLED BY
THIS.
CLEARLY THEY WANT TO AVOID
THEY'VE BEEN CRACKING DOWN ON
DESERTION, EVADING THE DRAFT,
BEING SIGNED INTO LAW.
ADDING PENALTIES TO THOSE OVER
THE WEEKEND.
THEY ARE, OBVIOUSLY,
ANTICIPATING SOME BACKLASH.
MINORITIES ARE ALREADY
DISSATISFIED BY THE FACT THAT
THEY FEEL SOME OF THEIR RIGHTS
ARE BEING ERODED BY THE
KREMLIN.
NOT ONLY THE MOBILIZATION, BUT
ALSO THE CHAOS AROUND THE
MOBILIZATION AND THERE ARE
PUBLIC.
THAT OF THE REGION SAID THAT
THE MEN HAVE BEEN ERRONEOUSLY
DRAFTED IN.
THEY DON'T HAVE MILITARY
EXPERIENCE.
HE WASN'T RETURNED.
THAT IS NOT GOING TO IMPROVE
MORALE OR PATRIOTISM AROUND.
THIS AS TO WHETHER IT WILL
BACKFIRE, THE JURY STILL OUT ON
THAT ONE.
STILL EARLY DAYS.
IT SEEMS AT THIS POINT RUSSIA
WILL BE ABLE TO BRING MEN INTO
THE FRONT BY FORCE, BY THOUGHT
OF IMPRISONMENT.
SOME STILL LINGERING PATRIOT,
IT'S HARD ENOUGH IN THIS
PICTURE IS JUST HOW BIG THESE
PROTESTS ARE.
IT'S SIGNIFICANT ENOUGH.
FOR THE FIREBRAND CHECHEN AND
[INAUDIBLE] HE TOOK TO TELEGRAM
ON SUNDAY.
TO TRY AND SHAME MENTALLY THE
COUNTRY, HOW CAN YOU ABANDON
YOUR MOTHERLAND?
WHY DON'T YOU WANT TO DEFEND
YOUR STATE AND YOUR PRESIDENT?
THERE IS CONCERN.
THIS IS PART OF THE BIG GAMBLE
THAT THIS MOBILIZATION WAS FOR
PRESIDENT PUTIN.
>> SO HAVING TO CAPITULATE ON
TRYING TO DRAFT WH